peu
deux cent mille âmes l'armée demeure
l'épiné dorsale de l'état iranien
un pays qui se situe à l'extrême limite
entre l'ouest et l'est à la jointure du
monde oriental last plateau fermées par
de hautes montagnes son territoire est
grand comme trois fois la france 25
millions d'habitants dont 75% vivent
dans les campagnes
entrons
l'islam s'installa en perse en en 651
six villes dépassent 200 mille habitants
à elles seules téhéran la capitale en
compte deux millions et demi aujourd'hui
cent mille automobile la sillonnent la
rançon de l'occidentalisation dit
volontiers le chat qui pour faire entrer
son pays dans le monde moderne a
déclenché lui même ce qu'il appelle la
révolution sociale
plus de la moitié des terres
appartenaient aux grands propriétaires
la réforme agraire pierre angulaire de
la révolution blanche a déjà mis deux
millions de familles paysannes en
possession des terres de 17000 grands
domaines l'électricité pénètre dans les
villages l'armé du savoir des soldats
maître d'école et l'armée du
développement feront le reste
essentiellement moderniser le genre de
vie et les techniques attraper le xxème
siècle c'est très précisément dans
l'esprit du monarque atteindre un niveau
de vie comparable à celui de leurs il a
fixé un délai 25 en 25 ans pour
transformer une économie séculaire qui
vivaient sur la réputation de fournir au
monde les plus beaux tapis d'orient déjà
les pêcheries de la caspienne se sont
développées 25 ans et peut sans doute
mais dans sa marche en avant
l'iran possède une arme secrète qui
n'est pas seulement le caviar
liron unis le flottant sur une mer de
pétrole
tout naturellement le pétrole est devenu
la base de l'industrialisation trois
complexes pétrochimiques sont en voie de
réalisation
mais aussi des barrages hydroélectriques
et une aciérie à ispahan qu car l'or
noir 3 milliards 750 millions de francs
de revenus par an est le nerf du progrès
l'héritage de cyrus deux mille cinq
cents ans d'histoire